señora de manuel vázquez secretario
académico de la unam
canadá a su institución ha preparado
para el año en curso una nutrida agenda
de actividades culturales pero antes de
referirse a la misma quería que nos
expliqué al menos sucintamente para
aquellos que no lo conocen que es una
canadá
muchas gracias un gusto saludarles a
usted ya su auditorio
bueno la institución es una sede de la
universidad nacional autonoma de mexico
que se instala aquí en el área de
gatineau ottawa en 1995 tenemos 25 años
de existencia que recién cumplimos el
año pasado y se trata de un centro
académico cultural que se dedica tanto a
los idiomas a los cultivos de los
idiomas y a la capacitación de ellos del
el francés del inglés y el español
y también es un centro educativo de
formación académica para estudiantes que
están terminando su licenciatura
principalmente y que desean ser
documentos científicos en el idioma
inglés asimismo somos un centro de
servicio cultural de manera gratuito
abierto a todo público que trabaja todo
el año y que se dedica a difundir la
cultura mexicana la cultura canadiense
hacer esa ese puente de relación entre
estas dos fuertes culturas pero también
que la cabida a toda la cultura de
iberoamericano
entonces este este recinto de la
universidad nacional autonoma de mexico
permite además de hacer la capacitación
en idiomas trabajar en los espacios de
cultura y combinar la cultura con la
educación de la utilización de una
segunda o una tercera lengua para quien
lo desee
precisamente en el ámbito de la difusión
y de la promoción cultural decíamos que
una banca nada tiene preparado para este
año un conjunto de actividades una
agenda nutrida de actividades culturales
puede contarnos de qué se trata
y con todo gusto bueno contamos con una
agenda académico cultural como la hemos
denominado que para este año ha
construido cinco ejes de trabajo y
tenemos un primer eje que conmemora los
500 años del inicio de la conquista de
la gran tenochtitlán y ese es el primer
elemento también denominamos el arranque
del encuentro de dos mundos también va
seguido de un segundo eje que son los
200 años la conmemoración de los 200
años de la culminación de la
independencia de mexico dos fechas
fundamentales en la historia de nuestro
país de méxico son 500 y 200 años pero
se agrega con una suerte de números que
se combinan los 50 años de conmemoración
de la interculturalidad del canal pues
nos vemos obligados a ver esa conexión y
hacer la actividad cultural en torno a
los 500 años de el inicio de la
conquista los 200 de la culminación de
la independencia y los 50 años de la
interculturalidad que no significan una
oportunidad como puente de relación
entre dos naciones hermanas como son
canadá y méxico
el segundo eje que tenemos se dedica
también a analizar
como la región de américa del norte que
puede tener en canadá una suerte de
difusión para que se pueda trabajar el
tema de la pandemia estamos interesados
en hacer un servicio público sobre la
pandemia y aquí le quiero compartir que
no es tan solo la una en canadá hay seis
sedes de la unam en los eeuu
estamos hermanados en una red para que
con una vocación de servicio mostremos
lo que la universidad nacional autónoma
de méxico hace como institución del país
de mexico y sus sedes contestan y hacen
trabajos en torno a este grave problema
que enfrentamos clasificando los
servicios en términos de los grupos
sociales más importantes estamos
refiriéndonos a la población migrante lo
estamos refiriendo a las mujeres no
estamos refiriendo a los niños a los
adolescentes desde luego que a los
ancianos que es la población más
afectada con esta calamidad que estamos
enfrentando
y el enfoque es de difusión de las
acciones que se realizan pero también de
las medidas preventivas y diferentes
servicios que puede recibir la población
para contender con este problema y
consumar la presidencia que buscamos
todos
este se combina también con un eje que
le llamamos de efemérides en donde
tenemos la celebración de la mujer está
próxima la celebración de un español que
también en el mes de abril vamos a estar
celebrando y lo combinaremos también con
otras efemérides que están relacionadas
con hitos en la actividad política y
social en méxico me refiero
concretamente a la independencia de
mexico que pasa en el mes de septiembre
y también lo que es el movimiento
estudiantil de 1968 en octubre que
también nos parece un momento de alto
significado social y dentro de ello
incluimos también temas más específicos
como la migración que casi a lo largo de
todo el año procuramos atender a través
de una exposición y un conjunto de
actividades pero se aúna a esto también
el día de muertos que es una celebración
muy
el concepto beso americano y del
encuentro de los dos mundos que nos
permite hablar de la celebración que
suena un poco paradójica pero que en la
cultura mexicana y cultura
latinoamericana incluso en otros países
tiene una connotación de recuerdo y de
oportunidad de que al recordar a los
muertos podamos volver a vivir su legado
y honrarlos en ese sentido y bueno
finalmente estamos este de compartir yo
esté dentro de este programa acabamos de
lanzar un portal en un entorno virtual
que le llamamos agenda y acervo
académico cultural miguel león-portilla
de la unión canadá que es un sitio
también gratuito donde podrán todas las
personas ver lo que se está haciendo lo
que estamos platicando usted y yo
ahorita pero también esto se ve en la
agenda pero también podemos observar la
historia de los eventos que tenemos
realizados de dos años hacia acá
en vídeos en actividades de mesas
redondas de diferentes presentaciones de
libros o sea lo que implica una
actividad cultural completa integral y
en torno a los temas y que la gente
puede revisar analizar utilizar en forma
gratuita lo único que pedimos es que si
los van a utilizar simplemente cité en
la fuente porque son un tiempo cómodo
esto es lo que estamos planteando para
este año y lo que tenemos para
participar dentro de esta agenda de
actividades usted señor vázquez nombraba
a la cuestión de la inmigración que está
prevista una exposición virtual al
respecto pero además usted refería que
el tema de la migración forma parte del
interés de una manada a lo largo de todo
el año por qué por qué ocupa un rol tan
importante para ustedes el tema de la
migración es un proceso inherente a los
seres vivos a todos los seres humanos
tenemos una historia muy importante en
ese sentido
en este caso para lo que es la región de
américa del norte estamos hablando de
más de 100 mil personas que han migrado
a canadá de mexico y otras muchas más
que han venido de latinoamérica y
también tenemos el caso de los eeuu
donde hay oficialmente más de 38
millones de personas que han migrado por
motivos de trabajo esencialmente y que
se han asentado en esos en esos lugares
nos preguntamos en el entorno de lo que
es una tarea para todos significativa
que son los derechos humanos nos
preguntamos si emigrar es un derecho
como conceptualizarlo como lo hemos
vivido como lo estamos viviendo como lo
vamos a vivir y quiénes son los
migrantes cuántos tipos de migrantes tal
porque no son una sola forma de
inmigración tenemos una variedad muy
importante y qué significa este reflejo
en el desarrollo de la sociedad
qué significa también en términos de los
problemas de racismo y de exclusión son
muy dolorosos y tan presentes en
nosotros y qué significa también en
términos de la contribución entre los
países y entre las sociedades para
enriquecer la cultura y los productos de
trabajo creo que son temas centrales que
nos han forzado a
tratar de entenderlos de tenerlos muy
presentes y de sobre todo de respetarlos
sobre todo en términos de lo que han
sido los llamados internacionales que
tenemos para que este tema esté siempre
en la discusión y en las formas de
interrelación de los países dentro de
las actividades previstas
va a haber inclusive mesas redondas o
mesas de debate sobre esta temática con
expertos que van a participar debatiendo
discutiendo el tema si aquí
efectivamente en este tema aparte de la
exposición que es una exposición muy
linda una exposición virtual que la
pueden ustedes observar en la este en
este entorno virtual miguel
león-portilla que tenemos este acervo y
agenda y ahí podrán observar que es una
exposición de carteles internacional
carteles que fueron convocados por la
comisión nacional de derechos humanos en
méxico y que en colaboración con la
universidad nacional autonoma de mexico
signaron un convenio para difundir
utilizar aprovechar este conjunto de
carteles que fueron premiados en su gran
mayoría la respuesta a esta bienal que
se desarrolló hace ya varios años fue
muy exitosa y pueden observar allí
carteles de la migración que vienen de
personas de polonia de eeuu de varios
países de américa latina de otros países
de europa e incluso de áfrica y que
también incluyendo a la europa oriental
y aparte asiática que tienen sus
representaciones en fin es una
exposición muy variada muy simbólica
porque son carteles carteles que han
hecho principalmente jóvenes que están
dentro del diseño gráfico como
profesionales algunos pero muchos de
ellos son personas que son aficionados
prácticos podríamos decir
tienen esa incursión hacia el diseño y
han hecho trabajos formidables
conceptualmente muy valiosos y en torno
a ellos se han podido construir algunos
elementos que reflejan los temas
prioritarios como usted bien dice
nosotros pretendemos que se hagan
durante este año y es lo que estamos
proyectando estamos convocando expertos
de la universidad nacional autonoma de
mexico expertos de las universidades de
canadá de nuestros socios estratégicos
tenemos una amplia relación que la
doctora alicia mayer ha promovido de
manera muy intensa y es nuestra
directora y quiero destacar la función
que ella ha desarrollado porque no tan
solo eso nos ha permitido ampliar el
horizonte de relaciones con las
universidades sino que la doctora mayer
le ha puesto un ingrediente de cultura
muy importante que se ha vuelto un
símbolo y un emblema de nuestra
actividad se ha colocado a la cultura
por delante y la migración en este caso
no si no significa una tarea abordar en
donde la interculturalidad juega un
papel fundamental por eso queremos que
no tan solo haya mesas
como usted bien lo dice sino también
paneles virtuales de discusión con
invitados tanto de orden canadiense como
de méxico y eeuu incluyendo desde luego
a toda latinoamérica de iberoamérica y
estamos también con el concepto de poder
revisar cómo está migración tiene una
naturaleza sociológica que debe ser
explorada en donde tenemos que trabajar
con la embajada de méxico en canadá con
los consulados hay una red de consulados
muy importante en canadá con la embajada
de méxico en eeuu y sus 50 consulados
son una expresión muy amplia y esto va a
ayudar a que se pueda tener una mejor
vocación de servicio en orientación en
términos de salud de educación de
incorporación para las sociedades de
interculturalidad y yo le quisiera
destacar aquí que tenemos una gran
relación con la fio la fio que se dedica
aquí a promover la interculturalidad y
la francis acción de hecho les quiero
decir que el premio garcía robles
es un premio de un nobel mexicano muy
importante que trabajo todo el tema del
desarme nuclear con el proyecto detrás
del único este premio se ha vuelto
emblemático de la universidad fue ganado
por la afi o precisamente porque la
labor que ha hecho en las mujeres que
nos parece un elemento fundamental que
no podemos perder entrevista a la fecha
todavía tenemos lacras sociales muy
serias de deterioro y desprecio hacia la
mujer y por ello nosotros destacamos
mucho este premio que la universidad
nacional autonoma de mexico le ha dado a
la fia para reconocer el trabajo
inmigrantes pero en particular en la
mujer
señor vázquez usted hacía referencia a
la exposición de afiches si quería yo
simplemente recordar de nuestro público
que en su momento radio canadá
internacional reflejó esa exposición y
mostró alguno de los afiches que fueron
premiados y expuestos en esa ocasión
lamentablemente no nos queda mucho más
tiempo entonces quería cerrar nuestro
diálogo preguntándole por el tema de la
pandemia hace un año aproximadamente
todos estamos inmersos en una vida
cotidiana que ha sido puesta patas
arribas y dice cabe la expresión por
esta pandemia de coronavirus de qué
manera la misma ha afectado el trabajo
de una manada
mire esto nos ha afectado a todos
indudablemente nos han modificado
nuestros patrones de vida y la unam en
canadá no ha estado exenta desde el
primer día que lo tengo muy presente
porque nuestra directora nos indicó que
tendríamos que establecer contacto con
méxico inmediato cuando esto se veía
venir en marzo y vigilar lo que las
autoridades sanitarias de canadá y de
méjico venían definiendo para nosotros
poder cumplir al pie de la letra con una
indicación tan especial como es contener
con la pandemia
en ese caso cerramos nuestras
instalaciones debemos decir desde el 16
de marzo después de una sesión que
tuvimos de información a toda nuestra
población a nuestros empleados y
trabajadores en donde les detallamos el
significado hasta donde conocíamos de lo
que venía y lo que nos permitió abrir lo
que se llama un programa de teletrabajo
tenemos un programa sólido de
teletrabajo que está avalado con un
proyecto que llamamos la contingencia y
que significa cómo vamos a entrar en las
diferentes etapas
de esta calamidad tan seria que estamos
enfrentando y como puede servir la una
en canadá sin dejar de trabajar en este
entorno de situaciones de limitaciones
en la relación interpersonal desde ese
entonces tenemos videoconferencias
constantemente todos los días celebramos
videoconferencias solamente a veces
sábados y domingos no son así pero todos
los días hábiles está habiendo actividad
del personal y tenemos instancias de
coordinación hemos fortalecido mucho
nuestros programas de enseñanza de
idiomas a través de videoconferencias y
trabajamos ahorita en un ambicioso
programa de educación en línea para que
los idiomas puedan ser cada vez mejor
expresados tanto en un modelo mixto
tanto presencial como virtual pero en
este caso virtual y no hemos parado en
la actividad
y promoción de la cultura allí nos hemos
concentrado todavía más y hemos
recurrido a la virtualidad le puedo dar
un dato que creo que es significativo
porque nosotros pasamos de tener 1500
estudiantes al año
en los idiomas español inglés y francés
y en este año que cerramos haber tenido
nada más un poco más de 700 estudios
y en el tema de la virtualidad en lo que
corresponde a la cultura nosotros hemos
reforzado nuestra actividad en redes
sociales las redes sociales han
significado para nosotros una muy buena
opción y con la intranet y la internet
que hemos evolucionado precisamente por
estas comisiones le puedo decir sin
temor a equivocarme entre amigos
seguidores suscriptores contactos y
miembros a la fecha sumamos más de 66
mil contactos
después de que nosotros hablábamos antes
de la pandemia en alrededor de 13 mil
contactos anuales es decir en estas
condiciones adversas creo que hemos
emprendido un proceso de resiliencia
institucional si le podemos llamar así
en donde hemos sacado pues una suerte de
oportunidad ante el problema
y en términos de virtualidad nos
sentimos ciertamente robustos no
acabados es una tarea bastante compleja
muy delicada muy importante que no
compensa todo pero que sí ayuda
significativamente a que nuestra
vocación de servicio en esta
responsabilidad no sea descuidada sino
por el contrario el rector enrique graue
le quiero decir hace un trabajo es el
rector de la universidad nacional
autónoma de méxico en donde
constantemente nos están definiendo los
lineamientos hay un servicio de ayuda
psicológica en la unam hay servicios de
orientación médica y medicina preventiva
también y la universidad trabaja con el
país en todo el proyecto de contención
eso nos ha impactado a nosotros porque
al seguirlo nos ha obligado a tener una
línea de orientación al público y de
servicio y por eso nuestro programa
cultural de este año contiene una gran
parte de actividades en torno a la
pandemia desde el punto de vista de la
salud mental y la salud integral
pensando principalmente en los niños que
están muy olvidados
una situación muy delicada en los
jóvenes que asimismo los campa diciendo
porque han bloqueado su socialización
pero desde luego las mujeres que en el
encierro han sido víctimas de
situaciones muy adversas y que nosotros
necesitamos revisar con toda
responsabilidad y buscar medidas de
orientación al público y de apoyo a
través de la cultura
señora de manuel vázquez director o
secretario académico de la unam canadá
muchas gracias por esta entrevista con
radio canadá internacional luís es un
gusto tratar con usted y pues celebro
que ustedes difundan elementos tan
importantes para la sociedad canadiense
y para la sociedad en general creo que
es una labor muy significativa